hold on legal go back to my boy
dutch smith bruh and let's see where
he's going how
fake of a name is that what's your name
dutch schmidt
i get a chicken bacon clearly on the
right card back from the top bro let's
take dutch off top
dog and this is long neck before
something happened to him
back off my broccolini get your life
together
too much cream in your coffee papa too
much cream
too much cream means you like guys sorry
you don't let your mom talk [ __ ] about
it i don't like guys you idiot well your
coffee makes a difference
hey hey mom how is my son
i'm doing all right we're just about to
we're going to do an episode again in a
few minutes
oh you're in california you move around
so quickly well i hadn't heard from you
so i just
you know i was just thinking about you
and
just wondering how you were doing and
i don't know did you um
how do you feel what are you why are you
washing something
no i had something yeah there was the
sink in the kitchen yeah
how do you feel kiddo i feel pretty good
i'm just kind of we had like a we had
that guy stevie come in remember him
from the
um yeah and he like had us set him up
with some girls and then
he like kind of lost it he like said he
didn't
even want any girls and he already gets
a bunch of girls he kind of like
switched and baited us or whatever they
call it yeah
bait and switch that's what they call it
you mean
that was you weren't filming though huh
yeah
yes ma'am we were and he just i guess it
kind of threw me for a loop
me too yeah well what about brendan
i mean did he feel the same way matt
yeah he's pretty mad he's actually in
here right now
you can say hey hey mama hey brenda how
you doing
i'm doing thank you wow
well i hold all kinds of surprises huh
disappointed yeah i am like imagine both
of you
are you know i mean it's really hard to
say if he
if that was his intent
you know or if he just like
flew off the handle or whatever the
phrase is that's proper phrase
yeah no it's i agree with you so anyway
i'm gonna get
i'm gonna maybe it's a little unstable
[ __ ] you i got so much [ __ ] in the
weekend
i can have a little baby on the way what
the [ __ ] you guys
i mean he's acting that way anyway yes
ma'am
i think it could be but um but anyway
yeah i didn't mean to
uh i'll call you back a little bit later
though after the deal
was calling when you guys are
shooting sorry no that's okay mom
all right love you ma thanks bye mama
wow she seems pretty disappointed
herself
well like she made a good point though
he might be unstable and we're not
thinking about that
we're thinking we're dealing with a
normal young 46 year old here
yeah yeah i can't tell if we did
something wrong i just don't even know
what happened
i thought we gave him brilliant options
you did brilliant the montana honey the
last
the big moose seemed fun although she
has kids
the first one is just looking to book
than the last one
yeah the third one ronald mcdonald's
daughter yeah it does
yeah these girls are all pretty upset uh
i think uh next time we have him in here
they might have some messages for him oh
really did someone
send stuff yeah yeah they just wanted to
like let him know how they're feeling
about the whole situation
they probably feel bamboozled as well
you think i do
dude do you work at jason's deli are you
a manager there
oh why do you ask would you like a
sandwich
dude you look like a frickin
you look like a totally you look like a
manager at jason's
look like
dude look at you right there that's your
son it's a similar
it's a similar logo i'll give you that
no similar colors that was y'all's old
attire
and that's y'all's new messiah no this
is the new here that's you and you're
not on uh kratom
yeah you're right i like i like the
collar i think keep that for the
sandwich shop no
definitely do you look like a crossing
guard at a freaking all-male gang bang
dude i look like a make a mean six lynch
yeah dude you look like you're somebody
who uh
who's sponge wash who's sponge bait is
old man
you look like you argue that it's real
tuna and subway sandwiches
it is real that shit's real to me
my back is my back is brisket your boy
did a personal pr of 600.
whatever bring that [ __ ] go ahead bring
that up what happened to you show your
mom this you [ __ ]
uh it's not no i almost blew out my
[ __ ]
brendan and i'm also on that pre-workout
oh you can have a trans kid after this
that's what i said
dude that'll trans your kid right out
dude you can't
that's a hate crime in most states
now i could i i could i was pretty crunk
i could
how are you guys zoo culture i could not
if it was 601 i could not do it really
not a chance that is all i have to give
my back is
super brisket and what type of
uh form are you using is that greek or
what is that
i think the romans did that that's your
normal roman
deadlift i don't think that i don't know
if that form was good what do you think
me chunk mold or whatever you had that
kid i thought it was good for him
i mean what you said i rounded my back a
tad but what's that heavy you just gotta
say [ __ ] it
get up yeah but how much is that young
fellow stunned at his growth and no
offense i know you're right here
but uh how about meatball huh yeah
meatball still wants to get on the roids
man
he keeps talking about it all the time
yeah when are you just gonna start doing
it dude
i don't know who to get him you don't
have access i don't know
believe me i'm not a guy i bet theo
knows a guy i might know a guy over at
jason's
cc delhi i'm gonna say i don't know if i
really trust
theo's guy oh what's this oh
wow huh uh christian oh he posted
himself
yeah yeah were you working with uh chris
hansen
he posted himself in the cats facebook
group after uh the
success of the new segment last week is
this on dapps dad's against predators
oh just stolen valor with that hockey
jersey
this is a normal picture except his eyes
you could tell that 60 mgs of adderall
right there
oh yeah you're on adderall right now uh
i woke up at like seven in the morning
and go to the gym
so it's starting to like phase out of my
system by now and how many milligrams
you take this morning
20 if you hold your breath it'll amp it
back up
heavy breathing will amp that adderall
right up dude what
yeah so do people light your ass up
uh yeah we got a couple of good ones in
here let's hear it
so travis white says you look like the
kid who bought a butterfly knife at the
county fair
funny uh not that funny sorry and sorry
travis but you knew it wasn't when you
put it on there
uh alex eakin says you look like you
dropped out of college to make
motivational tick tocks from your mom's
basement
uh bryce christian says you look like a
sun man in brokeback mountain
junior lee says you look like dustin
poirier with lupus
funny um like this right here you look
like
the jeans yeah you look like a stunt
double for wade robson
you know what i'm saying like that would
you look like turtle spirit animal from
entourage
yeah dude you look like a background
singer for abercrombie and fitch
hit him with that last one mike godwin
says you look like justin timber pond
and then um
uh he goes you look like theo gained a
few chromosomes and started dressing
like brendan
that's that's good which picture is that
for that one for
sure do you think for sure the tight you
know i think's tight jeans doug
which are now illegal in north korea
yeah mullets too you and i can't go
there dog no touring in north korea for
us
dude look i'll send one big black guy
over there from new york to beat the
[ __ ] out of everybody in that country
okay oh nick got lit up too i also did
me
you look like you got kidnapped there
nick that's like an isis
uh video you look like theo just tore
into you and they're like let's get a
picture real quick
someone said though someone said i
literally
always look like i've been held for
ransom that's fair every
every oh that's great you really do
that's yeah you constantly look like
you're prisoner of war
it's always a little dear to headlights
everything's new yeah you look like you
got lost in the rocky mountains they
just found you
nick looks like the geico caveman after
a sober living program
alex mcdonough it's the delivery man uh
he's a delivery man
uh goku aloe vera says you look like
brendan's cauliflower here
hmm it's okay that's all right it was
thoughtful but it's not that yeah it's
creative
uh shane meyer says your expression is
the same one everyone has when they open
the door and see chris hansen and not
bieber lover 6969
well it's episode's off to a jump
uh for a white guy you really have the
nose of a black guy
that's fair that's a fair point i've
heard that my entire life
you've always had that big noise like
that you have a big nose you think he
does
uh your guys is similar his nose looks
like yours if he got punched in the nose
everything's relative to theo so like no
one looks like theo has like
a bell pepper nose and yours looks like
you got punched
yellow pepper dog you have theo's uh
nose if he's a boxer
that's what it is dude i got this
[ __ ] leg plant wiener right here if
you want it son
okay down dog dude you know what i'm
saying bro my dick wears a sandal fam
shannon chapman said this is what the
guy in the corner of a cuckhold video
looks like fair that's fair that's very
good point that is well
referenced and that concludes what's up
cat listeners buzz buzz gang gang
you know what if you're in the gym like
your thick friend here and you're
pushing your body to
the brink and you're just feeling run
run down you know what it is a lot of
times you're not getting the proper
vitamins proper nutrients you're liking
freaking hydration that's why liquid iv
created a hydration multiplier plus
immune support to maintain and
strengthen your
immune system i use it before every
workout
um i use the hydration multiplier it
comes with everything man space like a
multivitamin in this little packet
they got everything man vitamin c zinc
wellmune
they got it all it's this blend is
powered by cellular transport technology
also known as ctt
all right which is designed to enhance
rapid absorption of water nutrients
um when you purchase liquid iv you're
joining their mission to help people
live better lives everywhere
so we got you covered man liquid iv
donates a serving of liquid iv to
someone in need
they've donated over four million
servings in response to covid19
the company has donated 10 million
servings globally all right
get liquid iv hydration multiplier plus
immune support in bulk at costco
gotta be a member though all right i
know somebody can get your membership or
order online at and get 25 off when you
go to liquidity.com use code kats at
checkout
that's 25 off anything you order when
you get better hydration today
using promo code kats lokid.com
gang gang draftking sportsbook is not
only my favorite sports book but it's
also america's top rated sports book i
love using draftking sportsbook
it's easy to navigate plenty of
instructions for new bettors nearly
limitless ways to get in all the action
my friends and family have been loving
draftking sportsbook
and i know you guys are going to dig it
to kingston listeners draftking
sportsbook is putting you courtside with
a chance to turn one dollar into 100
in sight credits that's right pick any
basketball team still in contention to
win the title
you bet one dollar if that team wins you
get 100. i would probably bet on
brooklyn to beat
frickin milwaukee that's what i would do
uh don't forget draftkings sportsbook
also offers great odds and promotions on
baseball hockey
ufc we got it all man draftkings is safe
secure reliable so you can deposit
withdraw your funds when you want
download top rated draftkings sportsbook
app now use promo code kats when you
sign up to turn one dollar
into 100 in free credits bet on the
basketball team of your choice to win
their next game if they do
you will claim 100 in free credits
there's promo code kats for limited time
only at draftking sportsbook
must be 21 or older in new jersey
indiana pennsylvania only new customers
only wager paid on site credits
restrictions applies see draftkings.com
sportsbook for details gambling problem
call 100 gambler or
indiana 109 with it well here's what i
want to say is that did you guys know
that elizabeth smart
was on the masked singer
really mass dancer no is there a mass
dancer that's
that's even more low level than matt
singer i i like matt singer the judge
are like is it
beyonce it's like nah [ __ ] beyonce is
not doing this
other guess is like is this tom cruise
like oh i'm vibing with that i think it
is tom cruise no
tom's not [ __ ] signing up for this
yeah it's like here we go
i would have no idea who that is really
no clue
not a lot of big celebs doing this
little wayne did one
i mean it's just does this blow anybody
else's mind is this insane
it's nuts it's insane they really
undersold who it was best-selling author
no she was the girl that was kidnapped
in utah
yeah but she a celebrity for being
kidnapped if it would have been natalie
holloway that would have been insane
that'd be cool you know what i'm saying
and god bless her and god bless the
smarts
um but what if they're like holloway
what if they're like oh it's charles
manson
yeah junior yeah that would be sick
right see that's oh it's pablo escobar
now we're talking dude and it's wablo
escobar it's a guy little has
one of his legs is shorter yeah like the
wall luigi
like wobblo yeah you gotta really mix it
up man yeah you guys gotta step it up
man
i think you know who do you think uh
would be a good um
mass singer mass dancer math singer you
you gotta go with crystalia oh
he'd be a good and he's a good dancer i
think yeah kind of you know what he is
no you can dance because you see him on
uh america's got dancing or whatever uh
what is that
dance dance dance no about about rap
battles dance uh dance your heart out
dance your heart out
lip-sync better lip-sync battle my dad's
favorite show disappointing
really that's his favorite show when he
told me i went ah dad
well i can't believe my everybody was
just so disappointed by the stevie thing
i i just that's
been haunting me a little like so i
don't know about
well i just don't know we're playing a
different game i don't know if we did
him wrong that's what i don't know
i think we set him up with four dime
pieces
and then he came in with a hickey on his
neck and apparently he's getting more
tail than ever
he's crushing tail and i thought we saw
a different side of stevie we weren't
ready for
really i heard him shouting as i was
walking i thought man what's stevie on
yeah i come in and i see you like this
what what
what he's like i get more [ __ ] than
anything
you have to say it and that's him right
there
is this the same video i think
see it i'm blowing his [ __ ] mind
right now i'm going his [ __ ] mind
oh my god see how things work out yeah
see how i love y'all you think i was
some peasants i love this park who
couldn't [ __ ] get girls you told me
[Laughter]
this is so blm dude the part about the
baby on the way at the end like
i can't get enough of that video and
then and then he kept going oh i was
wrestling with jeremiah i'm like
bubba what are we doing man what are you
doing i felt like we
were dealing with two different i feel
like you get stevie or you get weak
about jekyll and hyde dude
and weeby is the one who's got the baby
and he's in the strip club
they call him little weeby yeah yeah
little weeby
and how about even his carrot taker was
like oh
because out there i'm like craig yeah
craig craig i said what's that hickey on
his neck he was oh he flew a girl in
from washington
they were sucking faces
and then he comes in here and he's all
oh no nothing happened came from
wrestling
yeah you're dead to me craig oh did
craig get lit the [ __ ] up
yeah we're gonna wait till he's back in
here to try it maybe again
maybe not but uh this is yeah this is
his picture
god he i've i'm pretty sure i've seen
him on dapps
i just feel did one of us mistreat was
one of us too rude to
steve not at all or did we do our best
god i'd be so grateful if i was a single
man and you
and whoever the guy who was in my chair
was like dude let us take care of you
hook you up with these four dimes we'll
pay for your date we'll fly her out
yeah hashtag good guys man that's that
good guy
we tried we tried man people still use
hashtags
way to go you do obviously and so does
other people i'm sure what's his name
does
meatball [ __ ] yeah turkey spleen or
whatever that kid's name is let's go
we finally got the confession out of
stevie that uh he was already seeing
someone so we're gonna have to confront
him but other
cats fans sent in some confessions and
there are some pretty good ones the
hotline's popping off
uh there's definitely some i weeded out
because people are clearly lying
and [ __ ] oh they're talking about
killing people you can just or
or just like really well listen
yeah just the affair is too crazy if
you're listening after a while you know
what's up
yep yep yep what do you got but this one
uh it's pretty good
hey guys i'm going in with the
confession
my work which is subway
okay they've been welcoming
change out the expiration date tags and
replace them with ones that are
current and on all the meats and all the
vegetables
and i personally find that [ __ ]
disgusting so anytime my boss isn't
around
i tell the customers about it and they
tell them to get the [ __ ] out
and they usually appreciate it and bugs
and now i'm starting to feel like maybe
i shouldn't do it because
you know i'm probably gonna get fired
for it
i'll tell you this brother and i'll tell
you this straight up i used to do this
kind of stuff when poor when i worked at
the grocery
and poor people would come in rich
people would come in i would take their
cereal box and i would scan it like
seven or eight times just for the same
box sure
poor people would come in and i would
just seven or eight boxes i would just
let them go by and not scan them
and you do what you can do and then you
get busted and then you lose your job
now you're out of a job now you're
sucking on the government's tit you're
over there holding one of biden's nuts
you know you're looking for
free boxes right and so now you're
looking for the free box here and so
you know you do what you can you try to
help here and there you know give a
nickel to rand or give a [ __ ] dime to
uh
sharon you know you do what you can but
at a certain point
people who are going to subway still at
this point
in america i understand you're in india
or something you're going to subway
that's a
you know a seven star restaurant you're
going to subway in america you
ain't looking to live forever you
deserve it that's right looking to live
every subway has a bee on the door and
there's usually a roach holding it up
with one of his arms
she's a few roaches holding it like this
it is going downhill since jared from
subway's sister
allegedly gave me a b.j
in the french quarter back in the day
what's up jared
scott don't worry about it he liked
those four he liked those four inch
rounds baby yeah
and look man at a certain age you can
only mess with six inches or above baby
but uh god bless him and god bless
anybody he molested
and um and i'm just saying man you do
what you can but you also you gotta stay
gainfully employed you do you gotta you
gotta do the you gotta do the work man
this is what you signed up for you do
subway was flying under the radar with
these dark arts of course the me too old
but if someone does order the tuna you
know that [ __ ] god foul
there we go the tuna yeah don't get the
tuna daddy yeah let's
get sick with the tuna if it's a nine
day old cheddar cheese
let it fly daddy but if it's a six-inch
tuna
a six-inch tuna that's two weeks old
yeah yeah
you gotta draw the line that's why i
draw the line on the tuna dog
sometimes if you hit him with that tuna
you also maybe hit him with a little
uh antihistamine pill or something
that'll take that edge off
maybe some antibiotics and a foot long
yeah hit him with that z
pack on the back yeah daddy i think
there's ways to combat it you know
uh hit him with that doxycycline at the
end slipping if you could call
and let your boy know i fancy myself a
foot long meatball
if you just call and let me know if it's
real meat so i can move on with my life
that'd help me out yeah
yeah and so brendan obviously the type
of guy that still eats there no i
haven't been in a long time but i am
craving a meatball
so dude it sounded like you're just
craving a ball homie
so who's the last person who needed a
subway
oh he was you ate that subway no you
also get coffee with
dunkin donuts don't [ __ ] on duncan
duncan's fire dunkin donuts is the best
coffee in america dude thank you
you know who else drinks duncan huh isis
and you guys
aren't american if you're drinking
[ __ ] duncan that's on record so
it's an american company where's the
baseball dude i i think it's
based out of the east coast it's based
out of [ __ ] in the middle east it's
better than
let's go to sheboygan dunk sheboygan
dunkin donuts closes down
let me show you coffee let me show you
freaking tit homos what's going on first
dunkin was
opened in here we go right here where at
mass
massachusetts quincy
is closed following an arson over the
weekend police say a teenager
is responsible for all that damage
newswatch 16's nikki cries joins us live
from the central pennsylvania newsroom
with more tonight nikki
vicki looks sad as [ __ ] julie a lot of
people in shimokin
are upset that dunkin donuts is closed
because they didn't have anywhere else
to go for coffee and donuts
today we also learned new information
about the teenage girl police
charged with setting the place on fire
yellow tape surrounds the dunkin donuts
on west sunbury street in shimokin
the popular donut shop is closed until
further notice because of extensive fire
damage
there's a lot of people that's
definitely going to miss it no doubt
about it
a teenager is charged with starting a
fire inside the restaurant on saturday
night
shimokin police officer ray psycho says
no one was hurt a
psycho your freaking police officer
named
ray psycho bro raikko probably turns
that body cam
off if you catch me yeah dude
ray take a [ __ ] few people out right
turn that camera oh my bad i forgot to
turn that [ __ ] on yeah yeah
he's the only police officer that has a
couple of teardrop tattoos
off his left cobweb on his elbow
let's go officer psycho and this one you
get for why are you staying open on
saturday night you're a donut shop
you're selling donuts apparently it's
all they had in that city though damage
psycho says the fire was started inside
the women's
bathroom the toilet paper dispenser was
lit on fire and within about a minute
the entire place was filled up with
smoke
the mother did explain that she's
recently been put on new medication
right now the 13 year old who admitted
to setting the fire is currently at the
detention center
now i have to rely on myself to go to
maybe a turkey hill or something where i
don't like their donuts i rather the
donuts at dunkin donuts
and i'm kind of dealing with it but i
really miss dunkin donuts
okay i'll go down donut again croissant
or i get some coffee
powerade if i'm dehydrated i sit there
all the time
if i have any like legal work that i
need to do
more don't miss that place it hold on
legal go back to my boy dutch
smith bruh and let's see where he's
going how fake of a name is that what's
your name
dutch schmidt i get a chicken bacon
clearly on the right
card back from the top bro let's take
dutch off top dog
and this is long neck before something
happened to him
before he got electrocuted or whatever
stretched out
and how many times that lady say dawn
it's an indian turkey hill dawn if we're
gonna miss the dawn go to turkey hill
donna
but i really miss dunkin donuts i go to
every day i get a chicken bacon
croissant or i get some coffee
powerade if i'm dehydrated i'll sit
there all the time
if i have any like legal work that i
need to do i go there i meet with my
attorneys there
i'm gonna miss that place when if it
don't open up
yeah a lot of my friends go in there get
the cold coffee
with iced coffee i guess it's called
people
what city is this what cities filled
with these mutants
because i ain't going to their dunk and
dive hey we got to get dutch smith on
the line
there's not a chance that's his real
name duck smith
dutch is on the [ __ ] run y'all figure
it out
he ain't calling it our [ __ ] show
look and here's i'm gonna go this on the
on his uh profile picture i'm gonna say
at this point
it's kind of a thick chick with two kids
i'm just throwing that out there he's a
while there he is doug smith what's up
not him dog lives in shamokin boom
well his real name might be dutch okay
afterwards
very strange oh he's a white rapper oh
let's hear
some of his tracks son maybe rapt about
this dunkin donuts
dunkin donuts in the corn coffee what do
they call it iced coffee cool coffee
iced coffee oh here he is it's called
trust him
oh is he a christian rapper we'll see
and
hit it he larps live-action role-play
ice coffee dutch my beautiful blossom
my shrouded wolf my dark princess that's
edna from dunkin donuts did you get the
book
the production i did everything you
asked me to i made him fall in love with
me
but he always has the book and he keeps
talking about this jesus did you dare
say that name
well i don't know what else you want me
to do
here take this oh
make him eat and we will weaken his
connection between him and his oh
everybody's grandmother has one of those
and i will set you free no what happened
no
i gotta deal with this every day i lose
sleep
every day yes hit him tell him dutch
that's him right
yeah did you love me is it him
[Music]
[Music]
oh damn he's out there trying this broad
in the woods
[Music]
dutch is getting wild and now i love
this suit he has on
very medieval well well dutch is doing
it man that's what he's doing
yeah body armor of god he's a christian
rapper i don't know if he's coming on
this show
well i'm just amazed you could see he
turned his life around from that moment
when you know somebody that's the
burning bush everybody has that burning
bush in their life
that started a fire under his ass the
brothers might not be there anymore for
legal fees
would you say there i said the burning
duncan instead of the burning bush
yeah yep that's that's what we're saying
and here you go right there so there we
go man i think we solved everything and
now we can go home dutch is doing well
god so what was that guy saying that
they changed the date on the meat yeah
and he warns people and tells him not to
eat there he's doing the lord's work
he's gonna get fired
and i appreciate him but it's also
subway
jared is subway yeah it's tough that
they
like if it's tough that they they
shouldn't allow the sandwiches to be
sold to children i don't think that
should be
it's like vaccines well it's like i
think at that point even
jared uh or whatever his
i don't know what his prison nickname is
probably yeah to know it
big jerry they call him big jerry i did
hear that he put a lot of weight back on
oh yeah
but i heard that um i just think
if he's getting to put that still to
children
then that's kind of not cool at the very
least they should not allow
the children to have the meats anymore
kids shouldn't even be allowed in subway
let's be honest
like that's the part i don't think you
should be allowed around the sister
that's my personal opinion what is it oh
me
yeah let's go ahead but those are the
old days and those are different times
brother should we hear another
confession yeah yeah what's up
g fat k is your guy won't say my name
joey diaz this is every murderer from
every uh
cold case file episode i feel like this
has to stay anonymous
because i don't know if my wife's little
brother hears this or some [ __ ]
but uh crazy story
one time mother-in-law dropped her uh
her phone while i was shoveling and i
found it
and i went through it my mother-in-law's
a time piece
sure and uh i found some pictures of her
lingerie
fired the fire body okay 50 something
looking like she's 20 something yeah
that's a wreath
got a body on her okay and uh yeah
i got those pictures yeah you sent them
did you shout out to my mother-in-law
for dropping her phone
she's a baddie all right keep that k
take it easy hope y'all have a go okay
different show but still this guy's
confused
yeah dude i would love to see those
pictures what are your thoughts here
brendan
listen my mother-in-law's a smoke show
too but i'm not gonna stare at
pictures that's not what the man is tall
it's not where we're doing
that's why i'm in the same predicament
yeah my mother-in-law's a [ __ ] ten
bro but if she drops her phone i'm not
gonna text those pics to myself he has
some problems amigo
tell me this yeah
brendan sorry i forgot your name for a
second do
you if you saw an if somebody said
there's a nude picture of your stepmom
right here would you look at it
oh yeah i gotta look oh cause what's it
doing on there maybe i can help her get
taken down
that what that's nothing about that what
do you mean what's it doing on there
what if somebody has it printed off on
something it's on a piece of
paper well if it's out in the world i'm
gonna have to do a solid get it taken
down you know and i gotta look
you wouldn't no i don't believe you
no i wouldn't dude you hooked up with
jared's sister from subway
and he won't look at a picture of a hot
mother-in-law
you're lying yeah i'm not lying i won't
look if it's
like if my dad my dad had a white i mean
she'd be a hundred years older 120
but i would not look at a naked picture
of her i wouldn't look at an eight
picture of like your mom
right you know i bet god come on guys
guys take it easy i would not look at a
picture
naked picture of your mom nick would
yeah i wouldn't thank you nick i was a
chest that was a test
in your past because you're a wrinkle
hunter and that kid would over there
backstrap whatever his name is
talking about uh prime rib over there
yeah he'd do it wouldn't you nah
what's the oldest woman you hooked up
with me bro uh
32.
i believe i'm trying to say all them
like that's whack i mean
but how old were you when hooked up with
you like 16 21 was it a teacher
uh no just this girl i met at a uh party
through a friend
girl is reserved for women who are
you're right actually 35 and under
probably this girl well i mean
i'd call her a girl because i met her
for five minutes uh
then brought her back to my apartment
and i was sleeping on a popped air
mattress at the time and that didn't
raise any red flags
down yeah now does she look like a
warlock or not she's bad
okay if i show i'll show a picture if we
like blur out her
instagram name and [ __ ] okay sure we
will yeah we'll do that for you
yeah we can't i mean do we need to see i
mean
i would like to see her would you i'd
like to see what okay you're right why
am i oh that's her
no no no no oh why am i ruining the
phone you're right let's see her maybe
she's a smoke show
yeah well wait we'll wait on this this
is next that's megan olivier if she got
stung by bees i feel like
it's pretty hot this lady is hot i love
nose piercings dude you do
yeah do you not i'll get one i feel like
you look good with a nose piercing
what you'd like sick i would look like i
should live in a stable if i get my nose
pierced
dude you look [ __ ] dope with that
with your mullet the nose piercing
that's you all day get some [ __ ] more
bracelets on you you think yeah
like pivot breaks like leather bracelets
i don't want anything like a bird's
gonna land on
i could also see him with like a flames
tad on his neck with that shirt
like that too dude yeah be careful with
bracey wear too many
you better know magic yeah i don't want
to get
that oh there you go something i see i
feel that's a nashville vibe dude
there's some you can get that you can
put people's ashes in that are dead oh
that's a lot that's a lot of bracelets i
don't know
magic some [ __ ] native american but
on my wrist only that's
[ __ ] but also cool a little bit of
chris angel vibe going on
yeah i see that's the one that's a lot
that's that motorcycle
uh we don't want that for you yeah
that's for reserved for lesbians and
magicians
now what about um that is that's for
carpal tunnel nick that's actually
that's a wrist brace yeah that's a brace
but so that's where you go you got to go
less than brace what about uh what were
we just talking about
we're talking about meatballs hook up
with a 32 year old no i'm over that
all right and that man also has his
fingernails painted which is popular for
children now you know a lot of y'all
king sting listeners i've seen you on
the videos you could use some vitamins
man and you're like yeah i don't want to
take my multivitamin pill i'm not taking
that flintstone multivitamin pill that's
cool man what if kid drinking it tasted
delicious what about that what about if
your thick friend here gets done with a
workout and i drink my freaking vitamin
that's right
i do it with freaking athletic greens
because it contains 75
vitamins minerals whole foods source
ingredients including multivitamin
multimineral probiotic green superfoods
blend and more
that fill the nutritional gaps in your
diet increases energy focus
aids with digestion supports healthy
immune systems
all without the need to take in multiple
products all right we got you covered
man and right now i thought greens is
doubling down on supporting your immune
system
during the winter months although it's
summer so that's cool man
but you can never get enough for your
immune system
they're offering you guys a free one
year supply of vitamin d
and a five free travel packs with your
first purchase if you visit
my link today you basically never have
to buy vitamin vitamin d
ever again simply visit
athleticgreens.com kats join the health
experts
athletes podcasts comings go get around
the world who are making daily
commitment to their healthy
lifestyle again visit athleticgreens.com
cats
get your free supply of vitamin d and
five free travel packs today
when i'm at zoo culture working out you
see me in the videos i only rock
one set of headsets i only have one
freaking company that i use to listen to
all my jams or my podcast where i'm
listen to i'm working out
and doing cardio i'm using raycons all
right whether you're freaking
working out riding a bike a pair of
raycons wireless earbuds in your ears
can make all the difference look at my
ears man
i gotta be very particular on the kind
of uh earbuds i use that's why i
rock with raycons they look great feel
even better they come in a range of cool
colors customized gel tips include for
comfortable in-air fit
again check out my ears these are only
ones that can rock all the time
the other companies those white ones we
all know what we're talking about those
fall out of my ears especially while i'm
on my bike listen up raycon's offering
15 off all their products
for the kingston listeners here's what
you got to do to get it go to buy
raycon.com
kats that'll get you 15 off your entire
recon order
and it's such a good deal you want to
grab a extra pair that's 15 off by
raycon.com
cats by raycon.com k-a-t-s
dude is every kid gay now you can't even
find a straight kid i feel stuff
it's the new thing man is it yeah wow
they're confused
yeah a lot of your friends meatball
saying they're gay oh
no none none wow yeah start making
friends dude
we has friends very has straight friends
you know but that's
they don't like that anymore if you show
up with straight friends people
like you're not some comedians this
female community said oh
i see your crowd it was like a really
diverse crowd and uh
at zany's a couple of weeks ago in uh
and jamming the van in la okay
and she goes that means you're doing
your job
interesting and i'm like what do you
mean i don't care who
likes what [ __ ] my crowd's all korean
black i don't give a [ __ ] yeah
what do you mean i'm doing my job leave
me all this girl that doesn't sell in is
not have people come to see her there
you go you know
and it's like okay you trying to get the
per what are you going to try to get
some mole to
like a united nation she just needs to
get some fans
that's all that is so what's this okay
oh that's the 32 year old
damn me bally she must be a huge power
fan
nah this was actually yeah
no this was actually before power took
off this was like the last
not this past halloween but the one
before that and she has a child
no she just got issues yeah
yeah what's this little philly dove want
yeah
look at this nose similar to theo let's
call it what it is
a little honeysuckle baby hey brendan
hey theo so i wanted to set the record
straight on something and i need your
guys's help
what do you guys think about opening the
car door for your lady
even though you guys have been dating or
married for a while king understand it
love you guys gang gang buzz buzz
she has shed buzz she's more into me
that's cool
uh that's fine i'm sure your wife will
love hearing that
and b uh i do open the car door for my
woman that is a true i worry too
i do it all the time do you do it all
the time
you're not dating that regular okay i
get a real girl i gotta
actually open the car door she gets
upset if i don't she also makes me walk
on the inside of the street like it's
the 50s
oh really yeah i do but also
she's closer to the road that way no
you're on the i have to be
no matter where we're walking she'll
switch make me walk to there i see
oh that's smart i think uh
this lady seems like a good lady and i
think you're going to meet somebody soon
probably i would open the door for her
i'll tell you that much
nick your girl you open the car door for
your girl still
yeah i won't like sprint and like make
it awkward but like
if it's it's not on the way around you
can't like sprint around then you just
look like a city if it's
a digital choice yeah yeah if it's
convenient yeah
sometimes the valet guy do it for you
you ever open a door for a girl and
she's like you don't think i can do it
i'm like all right [ __ ]
yeah yeah and guess what you the reason
why is because
in the old days doors were extremely
heavy pull up yeah in a
caddy in a freaking uh ford ltd or
whatever it is
one of those one of those old school bel
air cars dude a [ __ ] group of
bridesmaids couldn't get one of those
doors open bro
and so that's when you really when the
man needed to do the door
you know you remember in bronxdale the
old thing
was named chaz told him he said what you
do is you open the car door for that
girl
you close it you lock your door before
you get out if she doesn't unlock your
door by the time you get around
you move on um
well that's insane i think a lot of guys
broke up with their girls
and that's horrible advice yeah that's
not good the sauce comes from mafia guy
you know
especially with key fobs now i mean
you're gonna be waiting for a while
yeah failed relationships have you not
seen the movie though theo
bronx tales yeah great is it i'm
thinking of what am i thinking of i'm
thinking of uh
fellas no i want to say like
fievel goes west or something think of
that but more mafia
and real people not cartoon mice yeah i
like is this aaron rodgers
subject this is aryan rogers this dude
looks like he is
but it's a neck tattoo of white pride
that's you theo that you could have that
you got i love this guy already man
brendan theo chin and nick
oh he's an artist it's your boy chris
all the way down from melbourne
australia gang gang baby get a mate
so today i've got a king it'll sting it
i am a stay-at-home
dad and i've got two beautiful kids
house arrests uh wolfy and nyla uh age
four and two
great names and um so pretty much
my wife will write out a list for me
every night and um i've got to complete
the list
every day so just for instance we've got
uh
washing cleaning mow the lawn
oh that means to use manscape keep the
kids alive that really should be uh
it's kid's life as a priority but um
anyway boys king or stinget stay at home
dad
gang gang buzz buzz buzz buzz keep doing
the lord's work let me tell you
something man yeah and this is coming
from a jason's deli worker going on
with people i want to say and jason
jelly has good stuff they do have nice
stuff
i prefer subway but uh with two kids
when i have those two little bouncers on
my own
it is beast all day dude
oh my god dude there's no time to
yourself you're not watching anything
you want to watch
you're not doing [ __ ] by yourself
there's it's all
focused on it's such a beast this guy is
it has the one of the toughest jobs navy
seals firefighters cops him
it's a beast dude two kids on your own
is a nightmare
when my girl goes hey this saturday i'm
doing this you got the kids on your own
i go
[ __ ] dang [ __ ]
and what do you do how did you plan
ahead so you can have like a better kind
of a running start for it or what do you
do
yeah i just take him outside we do a lot
outdoor activities
swimming i'll take him to a park ice
cream
the little dude a nap so that gives me
two hours to chill
do you ever doubt dose him up you ever
hit him with any cough syrup or anything
ah man
no it's such a beast though what's weird
to me is his
girl writes a list that would drive me
nuts
if i woke up to a [ __ ] list every day
do this do that do this
that's called a honeydew list they call
it in a lot of territories especially i
think the midwest it's a honeydew list
and i mean you got a honey do this for
me
and so a lot of men have those i think
you're just seeing a lot of more of the
times where
it's just a changing of the guard in
some ways a lot of women want to be in
the workforce and they are
now i mean we're in the place now where
like 20 years ago they wanted to be you
know like stay-at-home moms
right and now they want to be uh women
out there briefcasing around you know
i actually asked him i was like uh do
you mind if i ask what your wife does
because i feel i felt like he was like
showing a lot of his house on purpose
it's a nice house i bet she's a ceo
in australia she's about boss [ __ ] the
other thing is is
now like when we were growing up dad's
like they worked nine to five they
weren't too engaged with the kids
there's dad work provided you have
dinner with him that's how he saw him
now
times are different dads are super
involved unless you're a [ __ ] but is
that
also in the nature kingdom too is that
the same thing what's going on in the
nature kingdom do
the man take care of the
hunt animals did the man take care of
the baby animals i know in
uh for like lines the male lines don't
take care of the kids at all they
and the females do you know on this
great podcast this past weekend we had a
small a medium-sized animal man on there
and he said
that some that animals are really
violent and
raccoons well sometimes the male raccoon
will show up after the female has babies
and kill all the babies
just so the female will go into heat
again so they can have sex oh wow what a
[ __ ]
savage we don't want to be like that
right no no no no no
no brother male marmasots are basically
stale stay-at-home dads
oh but also if you're a marmisod dude
let me see what a marmosat looks
you know that [ __ ] is out the gate you
know other animals are like look at this
[ __ ]
those those weird-looking [ __ ]
monkeys
monkeys with albert einstein haircut
yeah i'd stay home too
saying dog these things look sleep
deprived homie
those dads are exhausted i'm telling you
man
take a nap dawg they look like they're
gonna hit uh
go back in time and hit 88 miles an hour
yeah
they wear makeup too man i don't trust
these [ __ ] monkeys yeah these boys
are on some jiggawa tell me for sure
uh should we get to the cats in the wild
yeah all kings stay at home dads but i'm
telling you man
as a father too it's such a beast
i can't do nine podcasts a day i king it
i just i
certainly support it it's just
interesting i wonder if it is the
best use of if that if it's nature
you know because we we really bend what
the laws of nature
are are humans we're also a lot smarter
than all those stupid-ass animals
well that's to be debated brendan i
don't think so dude
dude what has a lion ever invented huh
huh
a lion yeah nothing dude have you heard
of
lion king no
have you heard of um narnia yeah
who was the king midline yeah
all right what did he represent god
jesus did he really yeah that's such a
religious movie
c.s lewis is a big christian
everything's an allegory oh
this is my favorite cats in the wild of
all time let's do it
[Laughter]
it's a wanted poster and it looks like
it was actually up in a business and it
says
do not serve this man a chili dog
and it is theo let's do it on their face
can we get a better dude
serve this man of chili oh my god what
was he doing to the chili dog
ask him he's right there that's [ __ ]
hot
that chili man i didn't know that the
fish fish some people want creamer on
them
that's all i'm saying some people want
that baby backsplash on them baby let's
see
let's see that uh tres leches bro who
wants that
dress like chase corn dog mr steal your
motorcycle look at this dime piece dog
no i was just parking here i was just
standing near it
[Laughter]
uh and then this one someone says i went
off the deep end and started doing
stunts in my backyard
you just got bored and covered drop me
off to dub
tax printer this is for juggalos and
chickalettes
do not try this at home and i hope you
liked it
and what is this a gender reveal
this dude's a [ __ ] i think
that looked terrible this this kid
went viral like over the pandemic
basically he was putting out like one of
these a day
him just [ __ ] his body up yeah it
looks like it really hurt
yeah and this is why
this is the this is the young generation
man
this is what johnny knox feels he is not
keto who's he angry at his parents he
lives at home
yeah and they're like what the [ __ ] are
you building
but hey man do what you got to do take
it to the streets fam i'd like to see
him do that off a building and hit
somebody that's really starting
something right sponsored by monster now
i'm sure uh someone thought someone
found a picture
send me that please someone found a
picture of chin and his girlfriend
bro that looks so much like my
god captain wild chin
i need a boo who doesn't want to get out
alive
oh my god and look at his little leg
hanging out of that thing like a little
jingle bell
i'm upset he's not here to explain
himself she has her ass cheated out
i know she's thought nah ooh ken
uh someone found uh theo in a sweet
potato
[Laughter]
that thing is cheeked up dog brother the
same trainers theo
watch me whip watch me nae nae dawg doug
remember when she just had you doing
[ __ ] lunges all the time to build
that ass
god but he's still he's not the only one
cheeked up
we may have looked at this guy have we i
posted this guys to think boy bike club
that was a year ago probably ran done
look at the balls in his butt
bro that yeah his first team all bike
club
wow that boy is cheeked
up donkey that dude needs a cheekiotomy
dude not a dog
he needs to run that cheek check
somebody needs to glaze them buns daddy
fine i'm not dude
now this one was a reach but the
picture's pretty great they said they
found me uh
posting shower picks
real talk that is so dude
look at this family guy tapped in his
chest
my nipples are their wieners oh wow
that's disgusting
that guy looks like a wet chihuahua
jesus christ and that dude looks really
manscaped though i will say that
here's a brendan celebrating pride
[Laughter]
let's zoom in on that dome there
did they photoshop my face no this is
just
wow that's a lot of makeup wow
uh and then we got one more
[Laughter]
bro that that lizzo
lower body bro oh how does he find pants
god huh how the [ __ ] does he find pants
wow is he selling it to my brother that
looks just like my brother i am
not even kidding is your brother tony
ferguson
that's true i don't think you really
look like tony ferguson
also that guy must squat a busload dude
oh my oh my you know how hairy that man
is
what is he made out of [ __ ]
clay those that lower body bro
he's a thicky bun huh
man can you imagine the glucose in that
dude
i mean that's tony ferguson oh my god
that is tony
ferguson and you're welcome damn i could
see tony buying that
that rice rocket huh was a civic type r
yeah some jordan levin's on
god that guy is thick oh man
my grandma built like that man is she
yeah i'd like to meet her i'm
98 years old let's see her
i don't think she's on the internet well
look man i'm glad we just know what
happened to dutch smith i'd love to know
maybe we could put up a thing too if we
just know uh
i just wonder if we were too rude to
stevie but look the ladies have
some uh i don't feel bad for stevie i
feel bad for the ladies yeah
they put their hearts out there man and
the next thing he comes in here with a
hickey
it's like we don't know the guy but you
don't know when love's gonna strike you
brenda that's fair
he flew this little philly dove in from
washington sucking on his neck
unreal dude i just don't like that
switcher bait or whatever
you're telling me that this little thot
he flew in from washington's hotter than
that girl from montana
dude all those ladies were i thought all
the ladies were attracted to the yellow
yellowstone long daddy come on man and
it was an eclectic mix
yeah he can't complain we did our best
dude it was clear he just threw it right
in our face
it was collecting mix man we'll have to
ask him next time he's in man
we'll have him back in i think also to
listen to see i want to see
i just would love to hear if he has any
post kind of date thoughts and this
i don't know i don't know i just feel
like i don't know it left me feeling
like things weren't
finished in a good way maybe i'm crazy i
don't think you're crazy
i feel bad for nick and chin put all the
effort into finding these [ __ ] dime
pieces and it's
it's not an easy sell don't feel bad for
jin
yeah look his girl's true right girl is
treating him
just fine okay we know what he's into
we do what do you got nick uh we got a
couple more uh kingdor stingets
just got off work man jumped down this
little rabbit hole i found
i want to see if you guys are king of
the stinging debate club or whatever
just
just check this [ __ ] out [ __ ] slap
fights
they're fun to watch
we get knocked out all the time
that's just brutal i know if you guys
remind a little bit you see nick in the
background let me see what you've been
doing on your free time bro
but uh keep it up man i love you guys i
didn't really plan on sending this video
but
that shit's crazy i just want to know
what you guys think
theo look like you're gonna slap the
[ __ ] out of somebody
i like that guy i like that guy too man
i want to see that guy
slap slap box some [ __ ] english
there's nick in the back that's true it
looks like nick and chin in one person
uh out king slab box and it's pretty
[ __ ] entertaining i just don't get
how the guys
can take it and not get knocked out and
they're so
big they're meaty too they're meaty boys
and they slap you with those big dick
beaters right across the [ __ ] face
the crazy thing is do they make them
wash their hands first i doubt it
that's the least of their concerns oh
that would be what do you win
what do you win huh paul slapped that
guy
no i don't watch that kind of stuff god
he slapped the piss out of his kid and
knocked him out big dude
and he was in a slap fight yeah it was
like this slap box thing and he was like
i'll do it
and big dude he slapped him so hard he
knocked him out
man i'm telling you man and paul boys
are down to fight you slap another man
it's a fight you can't be just slapping
people i wouldn't mind seeing a tag team
match though oh that'd be fun would you
do it with me
look how big this dude is oh you missed
the slab doug
oh i thought logan was the one that got
knocked out no
i doubt logan to air that
it's a big boy they were slapping each
other's faces all red boom
i mean sure he's out oh he's out yeah
that guy's your body didn't fall like
that naturally
i bet you could do it if you wanted to
if you were doing like a that'd be tough
dude
could have been a couple takes too
though well you could also be one of
those uh
are we flat earthers in here oh that's
cool huh no i'm just saying this guy's
knocked out
all right okay
rolling boom
he braced a little though it looked like
i don't know i think that
it looks like it could be stay or not
stage i mean i'm not saying that looking
at a lot of knockouts in my day man that
is not fake
well
yeah that guy also could have been tired
who knows
i'm just saying what's going on you
never know what's going on in the world
diabetic coma yeah easily got sugar
could be low look at the guy next to him
might have a heart attack
eating an apple that he was probably
should have been eating
i love how when you're in a coma if you
always give you an apple like what like
if you're in a sugar comb or whatever
like diabetic yeah
when i was growing up yeah people would
be like literally have been hit by a car
they're like get him an
apple you know like what endeavors
always get them a banana
oh yeah you're dizzy yeah bananas
people love to hit you with that fruit
man when you're on the way to the lord
it's nice it's not bad man it makes good
sense you know
um damn well that's it brother that's it
we're here and we're there we're doing
it dawg we're looking for the lord baby
in jason's deli when can we
what uh shop can we see a new tuna
coming out do you
real tuna real tuna dog dang
uh pittsburgh just got announced that is
in july
i forget i think 10th through the 12th
pittsburgh improv and then ralph or is
it rally or rally
raleigh raleigh north carolina also just
got announced
get your tickets pittsburgh north
carolina you up dog
pg ptl baby come get slapped
uh yep and i got these dates right here
some shows have been added in cincinnati
in charlotte
we've added over there in durham north
carolina
chattanooga you got another one you get
a show you get a show
knoxville uh wilmington is still
available wilkes-barre
pennsylvania we added charleston we
added a show
and uh we also added shows new cities
portland maine
up there in uh in the black bear
continent
and burlington vermont i'm gonna come
and get that coat
so we'll see what we can do we also
added a new one in albany and a new show
in columbus
all dates available theovon.com tour
make sure to get your tickets through
there
so they uh the prices aren't all jacked
up and uh and i look forward to seeing
you
uh at the show that's it man we got some
great new stuff on the cat's merch site
wow love that merch that people could
check out yeah this really has been our
best merch drop i think
you know um oh what's up dog look who it
is
oh my god what's up big dog long time no
see brother
good to see you man what you doing dog
you don't look so good
what that's how i look
no i meant i meant you look you look
cute that's how i look man that's all
right
is that your merch that huh yeah i gotta
buy some of those thanks man oh you can
get it at jason's deli have you been
there before
look at this guy it'll be at ross dress
for less soon right for sure
big boy is going to attilies how have
you been man
uh pretty good we've been doing the best
his name is too dude
i know i can tell when you said man that
you didn't call everyone would you
forget my name not at all it's okay if
you did
no i might say but do you think he got
bad i felt like i didn't think until you
said it but then when you said it i'm
insecure so i'm like maybe he didn't i
said what are you doing
man man yeah uh your name's brendan
right
i think somebody said call me brandon uh
what if i doing the pandemic um making
out with
babes oh no arya is one of the best
stories ever
is dude we should get stevie out of here
we find him a love life
no i i got a good love life i'm making
out with babes i just said
you but you're making out you're not
finding love and what we specialize in
don't do finding love ask stevie we have
five
we had five dime pieces have you ever
seen what i love this is cats a love
five dime pieces five dimes how do you
find that many dimes
they you're looking at the best in the
biz bro yeah we are a freaking straight
up
piggy bank i saw that one where you guys
put
sent uh was it chin on it or was it nick
yeah you talking about chin the girl was
huge knockers and then he drank all the
sake
charged us 500 and then was like i'm
married
and you're like what the [ __ ] i'll do
that i'll definitely do that
would love to do that um but if you're a
playboy you don't need our help
no ari tell us about that one date
though that remember that lady that you
brought to the comedy store at that time
he told that story the last time i was
on king and all that's right
someone clipped it dude that's right man
how are you meeting girls in the
pandemic uh dates uh that's a great
question i i've been i've actually been
seeing a girl
kind of seriously we've been going on
like probably eight or nine dates now
i just took her to detroit with my
family oh and uh i met her from just
dming her
on instagram that's just we're looking
to like a lot of people use like tinder
or bumble grinder sure grinder yeah and
yeah
black jade yeah a lot of people black
short kings tall queens yeah i've never
heard of those there you go dude
but i just uh if i see a cutie i'll just
send her a heart
on ig or say hey what's up how are you
normal [ __ ]
normal keep it normal yeah but at the
same time they know what it is you know
they they've been through it if if you
slide into a girl's dm with a heart
or a hey how are you they know what that
means sure they know yeah if you do
anything
they know and then it's up to them and
then it's up to them especially they're
done which is what it's always been is
this girl a dime piece
yeah oh yeah she's hot she has a great
body she does this thing called uh
bar have you guys heard of that
everyone's heard of that yeah
i've never i didn't hear of it you know
what it is yeah you're a fitness guy
bar she does bar yeah a lot of chicks do
bar so she's in shape what she do for a
job though
she works at a tech company remotely she
lives their minds okay that's
unemployment yeah okay well it shouldn't
be she makes more money than i do which
is you know
anything anything at all yeah that's
everybody who's uh
that's unemployment yeah that's
everybody true you're touring comic
comedy's yeah i have uh haven't been too
much
comedy what about your van though or you
can throw some pictures of your van up
too will you
oh yeah i'll send you guys pictures of
my van it's coming along real nice i got
the bed built out
nice the desk uh all that's left to do
is the kitchen and the finishing touches
and then i'll be following you guys
at whatever cities you guys go to i'll
just be there whether you like it or not
man i love it we got some battle-borne
batteries in there too we went to the
show for those guys
battle shout out to battleborn batteries
uh shawn over there
hooked it up and they're a great company
and great batteries it's been i've never
ran out of juice not once
you just paid for like 12 batteries
right there with that read yeah yeah
send me more give me more [ __ ]
they're good batteries uh
congrats on the new set by the way thank
you thank you it's beautiful looks good
thank you looks crisp in here right
um well that's it man that's it alright
thanks for stopping in man and are you
now gonna go do an episode together so
that'd be fun yeah looking forward to it
love you guys all right
[Music]
flow is contagious browser outrage is
thicker than girls that are instagram
famous damn
hungry like i'm fresh off keto seeing
red like andrew santino
every song i hit like the great bambino
burning ate the queso and the quesoritos
but everything's gonna be fine hate on
me i do not mind
theo looking like the type of dude that
got a pack of matches in his pockets at
all times
they sliding into my dms a couple of you
trapping couldn't beat them
quit playing like nintendo ds you don't
want the smoke like joey diaz
meaning y'all edible just got my
eyebrows threaded and i'm feeling
incredible
brendan's son hit me up he said it's too
loud in the club can you pick me
[Music]
up
[Music]
on a string
[Music]
you